avril lavigne is reacting to justin
beiber revealing that he suffers from
lyme disease as well Justin wrote on
Instagram yesterday while a lot of
people kept saying Justin Bieber looks
like at on meth etc they failed to
realize I've been recently diagnosed
with Lyme disease not only that but had
a serious case of chronic mono which
affected my skin brain function energy
overall health it's been a rough couple
years about getting the right treatment
that will help treat this so far
incurable disease and I will be back and
better than ever
and Averell commented on the post
sending you love and strength then she
made her own Instagram post where she
wrote there are too many people that
have this debilitating disease people I
love care about and many friends and
fans I've crossed paths with to everyone
affected by Lyme I want to tell you that
there is hope because Lyme is daily
struggle for the better part of two
years I was really sick and fighting for
my life writing head above water helped
me get through the worst of it
but the bad days still come and go
there's a global pandemic but not a
global priority I never want others to
suffer the way I did and because of that
is now my mission to raise awareness and
funds to help eradicate it's
life-altering disease she then went on
to highlight the Avril Lavigne
foundation which is working to find a
cure for the disease and how people can
help
we surprised that Justin has Lyme
disease absolutely yeah it's something I
never would have imagined that that's
why he was laying low or yeah cuz
nothing he has been laying so low yeah
it's just because he has kind of talked
about the past Kabir is like he's the
step away from social media so you know
he's going by his own admission to about
you know quote-unquote mental health
struggles and and things that he'd gone
through and him sort of wanting to to
change his image and understanding
things he had done in the past and that
all coming back to mental health issues
but this Lyme disease thing is a real
thing we know from what we saw with
Avril Lavigne's experience that it can
be it's really tough it's a very very
serious thing I do like that he called
out people on his Instagram seeing you
know I've been getting all this hate
write for a long time about how I look
and like now I can finally say these
things these are serious things are
happening
Paulus's that bothered me seeing all the
hurtful comments but justin bieber
yesterday i was treated for the Lyme
disease and i film for him dennis is
proud of all she's been working hard to
raise awareness a Samantha says it is
odd that both Avril and Justin are
Canadians what American celebrity do you
know has Lyme disease I mean Shania
Twain had it as well other Canadian he
and we know the Hadid sisters and the
mom I believe had Yolanda as well yeah
yeah that's the one thing that I didn't
know a lot about Lyme disease and it is
surprising how many of these
high-profile celebrities have it I know
what the statistics are of how many
people have Lyme but to have those
credit like what she's doing with the
raising awareness for this I mean I
don't remember really being in the
conversation no until she started
talking but it is yeah like I know what
the statistics are but it is surprising
you have like three huge superstars yeah
yeah we'll have it all of ya all from
Ontario yeah yeah census I didn't know
about Shania having it curious is my
mother got hit with it
and NOAA says Lyme is no joke I feel
sorry for him I hope he gets the right
treatment and be well soon regardless of
his behavior online yet Omar says these
diseases are very debilitating yeah they
really are